شاب صيني عندما تتحدث اليه لن تشك للحظات
بانه ليس عربيا وخليجيا بتحديد احمد
الصيني كما يطلق عليه استضاع تحقيق الشهره
واسعه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وخاصه
على تطبيق تيك توك من خلال فيديوهات تظهر
واتقانه للغه العربيه وتحديدا اللهجه
الخليجيه يقدم محتوى ممتع ومتنوع من خلال
مشاركته اليوميه مع المتابعين ويدمج بين
الثقافه الصينيه والخليجيه حتى من خلال
الازياء في كثير من الاوقات كما شارك في
التمثيل في المسلسل الخليجي سكه سفر فما
سر حب وتعلق بالثقافه الخليجيه
[موسيقى]
وانت وانت
ما شاء الله تتقن اللغه العربيه حدثنا كيف
تعلمتها لماذا اخترت اللغه العربيه شو
يصير حبك لها
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ومن صغري حسيت اني احب اول شيء طبعا
الاسلام ثم اللغه العربيه
وكنت وان انا صغير كنت دائما اركز على اني
ما اغلط الكلام اذا غلطت مره لا يمكن غلط
مرتين فالحمد لله طولت الين ما تحسن لغتك
طيب
احمد ليه الصين عندها سياسه الطفل الواحد
بس ما شاء الله عليه كسرت قواعد
اسيا لك الحمد عندي سبع اطفال
فاكبرهم 33
واصغرهم سنه
كذلك
بالصدفه انا كنت همم دائما اسافر بين
السعوديه والامارات بحكم ان شاء الله
وتعرفت على صديق جدا
[موسيقى]
انت بتحكي خليجي وبتمثل كمان خليجي بتعرف
تغني خليجي وتغني لنا هلا مباشره
[موسيقى]
اه جلسه مع الاهل طبعا ما هي متعوده على
الاكلات الصينيه
في بدايه الامر اوه لا لا لا لا لا
شوي شوي
خلاص مهو وصل اكل صيني اكثر من السعوديه
[موسيقى]
يا شباب الاغاني الوصل الصين